what it is is the people that are
running [__] are so [__] greedy yeah
that they can't give anybody their fair
share they want to keep all of it that's
why it's like that way not because it's
a confusing blah blah blah it isn't it's
the game that's going on in our business
right now they're acting like you know
there's no money
you just bought your third [__]
Mansion yeah they don't want to pay
anybody and it's that disease of every
year you gotta earn more it's Bob Iger
going this is not a good time for the
strike after he signs a contractor he
gets 26 million a year I've done my job
so good that I've decided I'm giving
myself a bonus back in the day the mob
would skim yeah that's what they're
doing yeah but they call it a bonus and
it's totally legal that true TV guy that
guy gave himself like 150 million bucks
hilarious Impractical Jokers making all
their money and then he's like give me
that [__] A-Rod deal Bobby Bonilla
day they're getting all Bobby Bonilla
paychecks there's three people doing
that fire two of them and now you have
to do all three of those jobs I just
saved this company